very based take from a man in the UFC
named Sean Strickland
and I thought this might be the most
based man I have seen in my life
this is a great take we need to go back
to like taking women out of the
workforce maybe that's where we [__]
up you guys we let women vote no offense
think about America prior to women
voting they try to ban alcohol I don't
even drink but I'm not trying to ban
alcohol so what you did man you let
these women come in the workforce now we
make less money you got kids raising
themselves on [__] Tick Tock we need
to go back to like 1942 you know maybe
1958 after he [__] up the Germans we
need to put women back in the kitchen we
need to take [__] only one man needs
to be working so I think as a collective
Man Group we need to elect somebody
that's going to put women back in the
kitchen put one man working ways of
wages and build a [__] wall
have you ever thought about going to
therapeuticia for what